おっ
皆さんにとって
強い国や地域はありますか
少し考えてみてください
何が思い浮かびましたかねぇ
ではなんでその場所は強いんでしょうか
その国や地域のことをどのくらい知っていらっしゃいますか
もしかしたらあまりご存じないだけなのかも知れませ
今思い浮かべていただいた場所は皆さんがいらっしゃる場所から
謄本いいでしょうか
でしょうか
倫理的に近いのか遠いのか
物理的にはどうでしょうか
その土地に住む人々についても想像してみてください
怖いですか
その土地に暮らす人々の日々の生活とか
新庄悩みとか
考えたことはありますか
いろんな思いがあると思うんですけれども知らないとか得体の知れないと思うものに
対して私たちは怖いという感情を抱くのが普通なのではないかなというふうに思ってい
ます
私もかつて湖は良い場所がありました
でもしようとしてみると白井にその
漠然と抱いていた強さが薄れているということに気がつきました
その一つが中東でした
私が小学校3年生のときに9.11が起こりました
その当時はもう何か大変なことが起こった程度にしか考えていなかったんですけど
中学高校と年齢を重ねに重ねるに連れて行
漠然等秋冬=テロを憩える危ないっていうイメージを自分自身が痛いてしまっていると
いうことに気がつきました
でもそこにも人はいっぱい住んでいる
っていうことはそこに住んでいる人々の毎日の生活があって日々の悩みがあるはずです
よね
大学では言語を学んで義務を通してそこに住んでいる人々の暮らしを知りたいと思う
ようになってアラビア語を勉強していました
を学んでいると白井とその漠然と抱いていた強さが薄すぎているということに血がつい
たんです
ただこの中東地域と日本というところは物理的に距離が離れているんですよね
だからこういう想像がしにくいのだと思っていました
でも私にはもう一つ物理的には近いんだけれども
漠然と強さを抱いている場所がありました
そこが
北朝鮮でした
私は2014年から日本と朝鮮民主主義人民共和国の学生との交流事業に携わらせて
いただいてきました
南北コリアと日本の友だち展という活動に携わりながら
2014年に初めて平壌を訪れました
以後2015年2016年と計3回訪朝して平壌外国語大学で日本語を学んでいる学生
との交流を行っています
ところでこの朝鮮民主主義人民共和国という国のことを皆さんどのくらいご存じ
でしょうか
私は調べるまではコード小学校へ
北朝鮮というところは鎖国をしているようなイメージを抱いていて国交を結んでいる国
もせいぜい10%ぐらいしからいいんじゃないかなという勝手な思い込みをしていまし
た
これせっかくなんで皆さんにも聞いていると思うんですけれども
朝鮮民主主義人民共和国という国が国交結んでいる国の数
どのくらいあると思われるでしょうか選んだから準備してきたので1人1回池を上げて
みてくださいね
美味しいですがでは1番目36か国地域だと思う人
はいありがとうございます
2番387カ国地域だと思う人
秋谷線この辺で半分くらいかかりましたかね
たち135カ国地域だと
はいやつです西164んじゃないかって思う人
はいありがとうございます
これ正解は
最後の164か告知なんですけどこれ
意外と多いなって思われませんでしたか
今皆さんの知らないがスポーツ
いました
これが強いを減らす第一歩
なんです
2014年8月に私は初めて今日家に迎えましたと言っても初めて投稿する前は周りの
ほぼすべての人に帰ってこれるノーと言った言葉をかけられていました
んまあそれまでは未知の世界への好奇心が勝っていたんですけれどもまあでもそんな
言葉をかけられたらまぁちょっと不安にもなります
こ
ときどつとワクワクが入り混じった何とも言えない感情で今日家に向かったわけです
初めて向かった平壌はこんな感じでした
ここで巨やん外国語大学の日本語学科の学生と交流を行うわけです
そもそもこの日本から北朝鮮というところに渡航する人は非常に少ないですからこう
いう彼ら日本語を学んでいる彼らが
なのみの日本人に合う近いっていう滅多にありません
実際私がこういうした提案外大の学生もホモの日本人に氷を通して走り体であったそう
です
一方の私も現地に暮らす人々と初めて出会うわけで最初は本当に緊張していました
この日本から見た北朝鮮というところは核ミサイル拉致といったネガティブなイメージ
がありますけれども
一方で今日にゃんの学生から見た日本にもネガティブなイメージがあるわけです私がて
あってピアノ学生に日本人のイメージについて聞いてみると誰似
習ったわけではないんだけれども日本人はこう3月がきつくて自分が思っていることを
通さないと気が済まない人人っていうようなイメージを抱いていたといいます
でも氷を通してそうではない人もいるということがわかったいい一方かくいう私もこの
北朝鮮の学生に対してはこう抑圧されてい
いって自分の思っていることも言えないかわいそうな人々というなマクとここ上から
目線の見方をしていたわけです
でもそうでもない学生との出会いがありました
公表している最中には毎日お互いに感想を紙に書いて残すことにしていました
日本人学生がまだて8名前後平壌外大の学生が10名前後で交流をしているんです
けれどもこれはそのうち平壌ガイダーの学生の一人が書いてくれた感想の一部です
最初の日は本当に緊張でしたでも皆さんと話し合うとその緊張さは瞬間になくなりまし
た
あなたたちも緊張したんでしょう
それから決して日本語が難しくなかった
このあなたたちも緊張したんでしょうというところがとても大事だと思うんです
このあなたたちというのは私たち日本人学生のことです彼は荒涼として初めて日本人に
出会ったんだけれどもこのように支えてくれた
これ相手を思いやる気持ちっていうのが大切なのではないかなというふうに思ってい
ます私はこの感想読んだとき
にとても温かい気持ちになりました
と一歩は言ってもどこか斜に構えている自分もいるわけです
私が集まるこの朝鮮民主主義人民共和国に投稿する前に抱いていたイメージは先に話し
たようなネガティブなものそれに加えて交換社会では常に見張られているという
イメージを抱いていました
またから現地に
いう時も学生と交流している時以外はカメラがどこにあるのかををにまわしてみたり
恥ずかしながらそんな感じでした
そして一週間後日本に帰国することになります
もうたキラもに入ると戻ってこないだろうと思っていた私の友人たちの期待を裏切って
ですねっ
待っただ
日本に戻ってきてから続いたことがありました
こういう
私はフランいるところにも監視カメラが圧倒的に多くついているということに気がつい
たんです
駅の改札バスの車内書店がの中などなどなど
気がつけば私が普段生活しているところのほうが誰に見られているかは分からない
けれどもまあカメラがたくさんついているということに気がついたんです
大西て相手がいるところの状況2歩目が向いてしまっていたんですけれども自分の国に
帰ってきてみると以来と自国のことを見ていなかった自分にも気がついたわけです
国や地域同士が敵対関係にあったり相手のグループとは相いれないと思い込んでいる
場所に置いてこそ人と人との個人間での交流が大切になってくるのではないかなという
ふうに思っています
私たち一人ひとりの言動が相手から見た
私たちのイメージを決めてしまうんです
私が出会った平壌学生は人間味のある温かい人々でした
まあでも正直私はもう彼らとは二度とはいないようではないかと思っていました
しかし翌年私は2度目のところをさせていただくことになります
平壌空港について税関を抜けると
前の年に出会ったぴょんやの友達がそこで待っててくれたんです
本当に嬉しくで
恥ずかしながら号泣しました
そのときに私の中で許家の友達がもう二度と会えない人々からいつ会えるかは分から
ないけれどもまた会える友達
へと変わったんです
この橋はワークショップを行いました
お互いに出会う前へと出会った後でイメージ通りだったところ違ったところ
それからこのこういうより良いものにするために必要なことの2つのトピックについて
話をしました
こうお互いに礼儀正しいさあだったり街メサ
優しいところは想像通りなかったと回答したんですけれども
興味深い点は意外だったところ
んです
初戦に側から見た日本人は思ったよりも積極的に話し合う
なったり思ったよりも静かな人々
一方日本から側から見た[ __ ]は
冗談や恋愛の話もする普通の人々なったと回答しました
そして思ったよりも態度や口調が穏やかで優しかっ
と言います
購入する前にはお互いにネガティブないイメージし解体ていなかった日朝の学生がこれ
が終わる頃にはお互いに優しくて平和を願う人々がいるっていうことを学んだという
ふうに記述しました
お互いに共通して思っていることを白金したんです
なんでそこが強いと思っているのかという問いを自分自身に向けてみたときその答えは
意外と曖昧なものだったりします
知らないからよく分からないから
とか
知らない
ことはたくさんあると思うんですけれども
今日私がお話ししたのはたた中数分なんです
もうこのたったチェス分で皆さんの知らないが
多分私がそうさせるよりも多く減ったはず
それはー心の距離が遠かった場所が少し近くなった
いうことをイメージします
物理的な距離は近いけれど妄信的な距離は遠いいっていう場所は多分世界習得の国の人
にとってもあるものだと思います
でもそこにも人が住んでいる
このことを
想像してみてください
近くて
近い
当たり前の世界していきたい
今日は本当にどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]